I'm sorry we're just girl talking here
we're here with a fantastic Kate
Bosworth and you have a new fashion
collab with Roxy that celebrates 20
years I know it's crazy I can't believe
it it's 20 years
yes which was wild we tried to pay
homage to Blue Crush in Charlie's Angels
too with the Cameron surfing sequence
that was all about you like she's the
coolest too Cameron it was like her and
to me more it's hard oh it's really hard
I mean you had to learn for this movie
and you did it oh thank you yeah
thank you it was really difficult I had
never touched a surfboard in my life and
I convinced Universal Studios and Brian
Grazer at imagine entertainment who
everyone's very important to hire me an
18 year old girl straight out of high
school by the way super small town
outside of Boston to be the lead in the
surf movie that was a determined moment
for sure I love your determination
because it's like yes go for it believe
in yourself learn the skills
and prove yourself and then here we are
20 years later well we have some Blue
Crush super fans here in our audience
who have always wanted that Surfer girl
style but didn't know where to start so
they're dying to meet you and get your
take on their fits
um in fact I'm gonna put this on because
I'm in love with this hat so cute
foreign
so Kate will you take us through these
pieces yeah so as you can see lavender
was a big color for us I believe that
Lavender is the new pink so do I
and I love lavender and it was it's just
like it's a happy color and it's it's
perfect for spring summer so obviously
you see it through here it's super on
Trend I also because I'm an 80s baby and
a 90s baby I wanted to bring a little
bit of that like neon 80s Vibe back into
the collection and I am trying hard not
to steal conwell's pants right now so
yep um but I I also loved the idea of
like bringing kind of like more neon
burnt colors in with a more pastel color
palette like it's almost a clash but not
it's you know so I and I like that kind
of like little terracotta to go inside
out too yes that's right it's reversible
yeah so if you want to be a little more
chill but you're a flower girl I love
this hat so much I love this collection
I love this dress so much it's like it's
just it's just such a like great easy
um dress to wear like to the beach and
you can also throw it on until I go to
lunch or go to have a drink or whatever
it's just a very easy throw on and I
love this one I love the matching shoes
with a little height too which is always
nice
yeah I like a little height but
everything is meant to
be able to mix and match you know like
you can take the shirt and wear it over
the dress and you know whatever it's
supposed to all work together I love the
bathing suit yes the one piece with the
bag you guys look so pretty
my daughter they really want to wear
bikinis but I'm like hang on there this
is like appropriate yes showing skin
very sexy but like also I like it that
was you in Blue Crush with those boy
shorts I mean come on I wanted everyone
to feel comfortable and cool and and
themselves yeah it's the right message
for girls I love it I think it's the
best it's so empowering you know I
always say they really walk the walk
when it comes to female empowerment and
support like the world's greatest female
Surfers and and just all all walks of
life for women so I'm so glad you guys
feel good yeah
um like I typically dress a little bit
more conservatively and so like this is
something I would totally wear to the
beach and then the yellow like I didn't
think I was gonna like be a huge fan of
you but I loved it on like the neon I
was like oh wow I feel so good and like
it's funny and like just put me in a
good mood when I put it on oh yeah the
next time you see me I will be in there
and the next time I go to the beach I'm
gonna wear that bathing suit and that
thing I'm just getting everything
[Applause]
and Kate
oh no thank you so much
[Applause]
well in the cover the entire Kate
Bosworth by Roxy collection on roxy.com
and select Stars worldwide
[Music]
foreign